problems and there is a whole field
dedicated to neurosymbolic ai
and another way that logic and machine
learning are kind of
coming together uh is in the field of
verification testing analysis and
security of ml systems
so that's the context for today's
workshop today's session
and the first speaker it's my pleasure
to introduce
professor pedro dominguez from the
university of washington seattle
if you are in the broader ai field and
neurosymbolic ai in general pedro needs
no introduction
but i'll go ahead and give one anyways
he
[Music]
as i said he's a professor at washington
seattle and
author of the book the master algorithm
he has won many awards for his research
triple a fellowship sick kdd innovation
award
uh and many other awards so without
further ado uh
pedro the floor is yours please thank
you
so i'm going to talk about unifying
logical and statistical ai
um using markov logic and here's the
motivation
intelligent systems have to deal with
the complexity and uncertainty with the
real work of the real world
and to deal with complexity we have for
starter logic to deal with
uncertainty we have probability but the
problem is that we need to combine the
two
and that's what this talk is about is
how do we combine first our logic and
probability
and then how do we learn and reason
efficiently in in the combined
representation
and here's the basic idea a logical
knowledge base
can be seen as a set of heart
constraints on the set of possible
worlds if you violate even one
constraint the world becomes impossible
and that's what makes logic so brittle
and hard to apply to the real world
so let's do the following let's make the
formulas
soft constraints instead of heart
constraints such that when a world
violates a formula
it just becomes less probable not
impossible
and so you know the more worlds the
formula the more formulas the world
violates the less likely it becomes
and we'll give each formula a weight
that reflects how strongly we believe in
it
so if a formula with a higher weight is
a stronger constraint
and you pay a bigger penalty for
violating it and then the probability of
a state of the world
is just the normalized and exponentiated
sum of the weights of the formulas that
it satisfies so that's the intuition
here's a slightly more formal definition
a markov logic network or mln for short
is a set of pairs fw where f is a
formula in standard completely standard
for starter logic
and w is a real number positive or
negative or even infinite
uh for heart constraints and now
together
that's the syntax the semantics is the
following is that together with a set of
constants representing the
entities in the world and mln defines a
markov network an undirected graphical
model
as follows the markov network has one
note for each grounding
of each predicate in the mln with
constants and one feature for each
grounding
of each formula in the mln with the
corresponding weight
now that's a bit of a mouthful so let's
look at a simple example that will
hopefully make things
clear and this is you know a well-known
example of
social networks and the influence of
social networks on people's smoking
habits
so here are two sentences in natural
language smoking causes cancer
and friends have similar smoking habits
and we can turn them into logic as
follows
for every x smoke sex implies cancer x
and for every x
y friends x y implies that smoke's x is
equal to smokes y
now this is simple but there's a problem
with it which is that those two
sentences in english were true and these
two sentences in logic are false because
not everyone who smokes get cancer and
not all pairs of friends has smeller
smoking habits
what we would like to do is turn this
into the statistical regularities that
they
really are and that's what we do by
assigning weights to these formulas and
turning this into an mlm
so this is a very simple mln now what
does it mean
let's suppose that we have two objects
in the world
alice and bob you know very small
society
so now what is the recipe is i'm going
to have one
note in my markov network one boolean
random variable
for every grounding of every predicate
with both of these constants so there's
smokes anna smokes bob
cancer and a cancer bulb each of these
is just a boolean variable for example
smoke sand is truly fine as smokes and
false if she doesn't
and then similarly for friends friends
and a bob friends bob anna because of
course friendship is not necessarily
symmetric
and friends and anna and friends bob bob
which maybe has to do with their
self-esteem
so now we just have a bunch of boolean
random variables
and now the markov network is going to
have a
an edge an undirected edge between any
two variables that are directly
dependent on each other
which means any two ground predicates
that appear together in the same formula
so for example we're going to have an
edge between cancer and smoke's anna
and now we're going to have a three-way
clique for each grounding of the second
formula so for example there's one
between friends a b smokes a and smokes
b and so on
so now we just have a markov network and
what is the probability distribution
that this represents
well the probability of a state of the
world meaning an assignment of truth
values to those boolean variables
is just the normalized exponentiated
sum over the formulas of the weight of
the formula times
the number of true groundings of the
formula in that
in that assignment so formula has more
true groundings
and the large positive weight will
contribute more and so on
i notice something very important here
which is that an mln
does not just represent a single
distribution it actually represents a
whole family
of distributions when you ground it with
different domains
you get different distributions and this
is part of what makes this very powerful
and useful
is that an mlm in some sense is actually
a program for constructing
uh um you know probability distributions
with all the advantages that programs
have
over you know doing things in assembly
code
and you might also be thinking that well
this is interesting but
it's not very practical because it's
gonna you know the mln will blow up when
you ground it
and in fact a good chunk of this is to
be about how we solve that problem
but a very simple thing you can do right
off the bat that's you know very helpful
is just to have typed variables and
constants so for example if you have
something like works for x y
x only needs to be you know instantiated
with people and and why with uh
you know with organizations also what
i'm going to talk about here is actually
a subset
of mlns to just keep things simple but
markov logic has all the features of
first our logic including functions
existential quantifiers and you know it
can
specify probability distributions over
infinite and continuous domains and so
on
so how does markov logic relate to first
order logic
well there's a very nice relationship
which is that if you let all the weights
go to infinity
then you pay an infinite penalty for
violating a formula
and so this just becomes first order
logic so there's a theorem that says
all the entailment queries in first
order logic can be answered by computing
conditional probabilities
in an mln you know with infinite weights
but of course the interesting case is
when the weights are finite
and what can we say there we can say
something very interesting which is that
if i have a satisfiable knowledge base
with all positive weights
then the satisfying assignments are the
modes of the distribution
so the worlds that first order logic
lights are still there they've just
become the modes of the distribution
and then as we move away from them the
probability decays gracefully as opposed
to falling off a cliff
but most important of course is the case
where the knowledge base is not
satisfiable when there are
contradictions
and in standard first-half logic when
there's a contradiction in the
base peaks fly and everything falls
apart which makes it very hard to build
very large knowledge bases or
collectively constructed knowledge bases
like
the semantic web and so on in markov
logic there's no problem at all if you
have a contradiction then you just
you know sum the weights on either side
and you get a probability
that comes out of that what about the
relation to the statistical models that
we use
in machine learning well again uh
essentially all the major classes of
statistical models that are widely used
are simple special cases of markov logic
you can typically specify them with just
a couple of formulas
things like graphical models including
markov and vision networks
you know maximum entropy models logistic
regression
um hidden markov models conditional
random fields
and in particular these days very
importantly many deep architectures like
the balsa machines the belief networks
and
and so on are also special cases of
markov logic
and these are all special cases that are
obtained by making the predicates be
zero
error so that you actually do not have
dependencies between objects
all that all that you have is
independent is independent objects
and the nice thing about markov logic is
that it allows those dependencies via
predicates like
you know friends x y and so you can have
much richer
classes of distributions so
this is all very nice but it's not very
useful if we can't do inference in this
language so how do you do inference in
markov logic
well inference is computing the
probability of a query given evidence
and an mln
and a set of constants and this is the
same as computing the probability of
mln where the evidence has been compiled
out just as in ordinary graphical models
and and of course you know the as we saw
on mln and the set of constants defines
a markov network
so at the end of the day the inference
boils down to computing the probability
of a query in a markov network
and this can be done using any
probabilistic inference algorithm you
like
including mcmc belief propagation and so
on
but there is of course a huge problem
which is that
the ground markov network in all but the
smallest domains is going to be too
large because
it's going to be exponential in the
clause area so we need
we need something else so what might
that something else be
well uh we can do what we can do here as
we're gonna do
every step of the way is port over ideas
from
first order logic in particular lifted
difference
right the same thing that robinson did
for logic we're gonna do for
probabilistic inference here
so what does you know and the the
benefit of lifted differences is that
now you can reason that the level of
whole sets of objects at once
potentially even reason over infinite
objects in in finite time
so so how do we do this here here's you
know just a high level
very high level sketch uh the
probability of a query
uh is is really just the sum
over the worlds where the query holds of
the probability of the world
and you know if this wasn't exponential
we'd be done
now of course it is so what do we do
well there's two steps here one is that
if a world can be divided into
independent sub-worlds
then it's probability is just the
product over the sub worlds of the
probability of each sub world
number one number two if i this gets rid
of one of the exponentials there's a
double exponential going on here and
this gets rid of
one of them and the other one is the
following is that if
i can group the sub worlds into kinds
that have the same probability
distribution
then the probability of a world is just
a product over the kinds
not the sub worlds of the probability of
any sub world in the kind
raised to the number of worlds in the
kind this is very powerful because
now this gets rid of the other
exponential
and enough now finally actually have
something that is tractable you know in
in on a good day as we'll see now of
course
in most domains there aren't independent
subwoofers because otherwise why would
you have you know a joint model for them
but the point is that if you condition
the more the more variables you
condition on the more random variables
the more you know ground predicates you
condition
the more independence you get so by
combining these two things
on a good day you'll actually get
something that is uh that is pretty
efficient
here's a small example to illustrate
this so going back to the smokes and
to the friends and smokers example uh
here's our mln and now let's suppose
that i'm going to condition
on smoke's x right meaning i know
whether or not any smokes and i know
whether or not bob smokes well
this actually makes uh you know all of
these
it makes smokes and smokes well
disappear of course and also all the
edges
involving them so now we actually get
something much simpler
we just get in this simple case a bunch
of
independent variables but now further
let's say that
we know that either alice and bob both
smoke or neither does
right then actually you know these these
uh six nodes actually just have two
different distributions there's one for
all the friends x y notes
the green one here and there's one for
the red notes
and so if you if you look at the bottom
of the screen here computing this long
train
of you know conditional of this joint
probability
just becomes the probability of cancer
squared times the probability of friends
x y
to the fourth right so now actually this
can be computed very very efficiently
right now of course this is on a good
day on a bad day for example
anna and bob have different smoking
habits so you don't get as much of a
compression you don't get as much of a
reduction
you typically still get some right so
one extreme you get something that is
the size of just the original mln
at the other extreme you get no benefit
and usually you're somewhere in between
and in fact you know i'm going to that
here but you can do approximate lifting
which is very powerful because
often at a small approximation cost you
get a huge
reduction in in inference complexity
so um this is embodied in a procedure
that we call probabilistic field
improving
and probabilistic improving is very nice
because it has
almost all the major types of inference
that we have to do in ai
as as special cases as illustrated in
this figure here
so if you look at the bottom left corner
you have traditional
propositional theme proving which of
course is equivalent to sat
and now there's three ways in which you
can extend this one is by counting you
want to count the number of satisfying
assignments so now you have model
counting
another one is by weighting so you have
you know the weighted sat problem
and the one is by lifting to first order
level
and each of these now corresponds to
interesting problems so for example
the weighted case is the same as m as
mpe
inference finding the most probable
explanation or the most probable state
in probabilistic inference uh the the
weighted
um the weighted model counting problem
is equivalent to standard probabilistic
inference like what typically do
people typically do graphical models and
now of course there's lifted versions of
all of these
and at the top right corner there you
have the full-blown probabilistic you're
improving
which is really just lifted weighted
model counting so with this
one procedure and and you know we have
um
you know an implementation of this that
i will that i will point to later
you can actually do all of these things
all the way from just you know standard
propositional uh uh um uh
you know from from from basic sat to all
kinds of probabilistic
and first order inference and these are
really you know like what we used at the
bottom left corner there you could use
different things but it's really just
dpl
and so what we have here are successive
extensions of the pll
all the way to lifted weighted model
accounting which which we call
probabilistic
improving because that's that's what it
amounts to
okay so what about learning so briefly
uh in learning data is no longer a
single table as in ordinary machine
learning that is a full relational
database right you can have any number
of relations
and that's what we want because that's
what the real world has the real world
isn't just
one table that we have to somehow you
know hack everything into
and i'm going to make the closed world
assumption here for simplicity
uh it's not always appropriate if you
don't make the calls with assumption
then you need
em versions of the algorithms that i'm
going to describe here which which we
also have
and of course there's learning
parameters i.e the weights of the
formulas which can be done
generatively or discriminatively and
there's learning structure which is
which is learning the formulas
so to learn parameters uh as it turned i
mean we thought this was going to be a
hellishly difficult problem because now
the data is not iad so maximum
likelihood
you know basically falls apart but but
actually turns out
to not be the case um learning is this
in at some level just as simple as
before we can use gradient descent
it's a it's a convex problem there's no
local maxima
the gradient with respect to each weight
actually has a very simple and intuitive
form
uh the gradient of the log likelihood
respect to a weight
is just the number of true groundings of
the corresponding clause in the data
minus the expected number
according to the model so if a clause is
true more often than the model
says then its weight needs to go up if
it's true less often
it's it's it's it's weights if sorry if
it's two more often the weight needs to
go down
et cetera and when they all line up then
then you're done then you have the
maximum likelihood solution
the only snag of course and there has to
be a snag
is that to compute the expected number
of true groundings
you need inference you need an inference
you know itself can be expensive of
course
and you need to do this at each step of
gradient descent so most of the time
this is going to be too expensive
so so what can we do well we can change
the subject right if you can't solve the
problem
uh solve a simpler problem that
hopefully is is uh you know not too
different from the real one
and here there's a natural candidate
which is something called
pseudo-likelihood
uh pseudo-likelihood is just the product
over all the random variables of the
product of each variable given its
neighbors in the markov network
and the the beautiful thing about this
is that it does not require inference
and it's also a consistent estimator so
you know it's it's you know reasonably
statistically well behaved
it's widely used but of course
it doesn't always work very well if
typically what if what you need that
inference time
is short chains of inference this will
work well because that's what it was
optimized for
but if you need long chains of inference
it probably won't because it wasn't
optimized for that
so so what can you do in that case well
in that case you can do discriminative
learning
and and you know in machine learning
typically you always wind up doing
discriminative learning at the end of
the day because that's what gives the
best results so
you know it's a good thing to do in its
own right and and what is the idea here
is that if i know in advance which
variables i'm going to be querying
and which ones are evidence i can just
optimize the conditional probability of
the query given the evidence instead of
the whole joint distribution
which is a much harder thing and
everything you know is pretty much the
same as before except with conditional
probabilities now
the big gain here is that what makes
inference hard
is that the probability distributions
are typically highly multimodal
right and then i have to sum over those
modes but as i add evidence most of
those modes disappear in fact
often all but one disappear and so now
instead of doing this exponential sum
over all the states i can just find the
peak the most probable state
and and and use you know uh the counts
in that state as my uh um as my
expected counts this is something that
is you know very standard
in fact you could say it is the standard
in practice in
in problems in most domains and and and
and we can use that here so there's many
different algorithms to do this but
a simple one is what is called the
structured perceptron
or an extension of the structured
perceptron which was originally
introduced by mike collins for training
hidden markov models discriminatively
so of course the restriction there is
that you assume the network is a linear
chain
and now you just do the following you
initialize all weights at zero
and then you do the following sum fixed
number of times uh you use the viterbi
algorithm to infer the most probable
state of the hidden variables given the
observable ones for example
what you said given the phonemes that
were heard in in speech recognition
and then you count things in that state
that you inferred and the difference
between those counts
and the counts in in the data is is is
your gradient you multiply that by by a
learning rate and then you add to the
weights
and then you just return the average of
this over all the steps
why the average and not the last uh you
know result
uh well it's it's it's both
theoretically uh predicted and
empirically verified that you get better
generalization this way and you know
it's not surprising because it helps to
combat everything now of course what we
want to do is
is inference over any mln but we can do
that by extending this algorithm in a
very simple way which
is that instead of a viterbi we just use
ptp
in particular we use the maximizing the
mpe version
of of probabilistic three improving and
the rest of the algorithm can stay
pretty much the same
okay so that's your basic weight
learning
um what about structure learning right
we don't just want to learn weights for
predefined formulas we want to be able
to discover those formulas from that if
we can
well if you think about this is both a
generalization of the problem of feature
induction in markov networks and also of
inductive logic programming
and you could use in principle any such
i you know ilp
meaning inductive logic programming
approach here
but but with a couple of differences one
is that
in ilp of course you just induce horn
clauses
and here we won't induce any clauses and
also in lp usually your evaluation
function is some
form of accuracy or information gain but
here we're learning the probabilistic
model so it should be a likelihood or a
vision posterior or something like that
and and indeed we can do this um
quite you know fairly straightforwardly
there is of course a problem which is
that
in order to do this we need to learn
weights for every candidate's formula so
our search process
is going to propose candidate clauses
every time we have a candidate we need
to relearn the weights in principle for
all
the formulas right because they're all
tied together and
well and doing this at every step of a
large search could
in this itself is expensive could be a
problem
as it turns out surprisingly this this
is not the bottleneck
if you do a couple of very simple things
namely if you um
initialize the weights at the at the at
the current ones instead of starting
from scratch
and if you use a fast optimizer like you
know a newton quasi-newton
lbfgs type optimizer you typically
converge in just one or two iterations
so the bottleneck interestingly turns
out to be something else
it's it's counting clause groundings
as it turns out counting counting the
you know the true groundings of a clause
in the database is already
uh you know an np complete problem and
and you know in in weight learning we
only had to do that once at the
beginning
but now you know we have to to
constantly do it when we propose clauses
so this turns out to be the bottom leg
but again we can get around this
bottleneck just by being you know
minimally intelligent and there's a
number of things we can do but the most
important one is just to sub-sample
all right if i have a clause with a
million grabbings i actually don't need
to count over all of them i can just
randomly sample them using something
like carpluby
and then extrapolate the number of true
groundings that i found to the number of
true groundings in you know
in the whole uh database and with this
we can actually learn structure for mlns
with roughly the same efficiency that
you can learn features from markov
networks
or learn logic programs which is not
blindingly fast not super scalable we'll
have a little bit more to say about
making this truly
industrial strength in just a second but
it's actually good enough for for a lot
of applications
and in terms of unifying these two
things it's basically now reaching the
goal
so of course in structural learning to
to now get you know more precise
you need to specify a number of things
the first one is the initial state
and the default is just unit clauses
right basically assuming that they're
all independent
a much more interesting alternative
however is that is to initialize with
the hand coded knowledge base
this is how we typically use mlns we
actually start by
you know getting knowledge from people
or or extracting it from tests or
whatever
and then we have a bunch of formulas
which are useful but probably need
repaired and extended
so we can initialize with with the hand
coded knowledge base
and now of course we need search
operators the obvious ones are adding
and removing literals
another very useful one to have is
flipping the sign of a literal
because when people write formulas they
often get the formula roughly right but
they put the implication in the wrong
direction
and so flipping a sign helps with that
and of course it help you could do that
by adding and moving a little
but but it you know flipping it gets
over a hump in the in the optimization
landscape that otherwise would stop you
you need an evaluation function the
obvious one is the likelihood of course
because it's efficient
but we have to combine that with some
kind of structure prior
to avoid learning you know as in
graphical models a completely connected
graph
and so a very common one is to just
penalize divergence
from the from the prior hand coded
knowledge base every time that i want to
modify the knowledge base the increasing
likelihood
has to exceed the the prior penalty
and you know this is just as in
graphical models and works quite
quite well and finally of course you
need the search method
uh you know common one is beam search
which comes from
more from the markov network side uh
sorry from the iop site charts first
from the markup network side
and bottom up genetic you know there's
many different papers about
how to do this and you can pick your
favorite method
so um are we done um
well not really because this is still
not really scalable to the kinds of very
large
knowledge bases and malls that we have
today and not truly industrial strength
right it still needs a bunch of hand
holding
for the inference whatever form it takes
you know you have to look under the hood
if you will
you can't just drive the car so what can
we do well again
we're just going to take a page from you
know classic ai
and we're going to look at tractable
subsets right in the same way that
people
spent well actually they're still doing
this right but it started in the 70s
like
looking at tractable subsets of first
order logic we're going to look at
tractable subsets of markov logic
so here's one that we've introduced it's
called tractable markov
logic and not surprisingly it's a
description
logic type language it's object oriented
there's a class hierarchy
and there's a subpart hierarchy and as
long as the dependencies are mediated by
that hierarchy
you can actually do inference in time
that is linear
linear in the number of rules and
objects uh in in the model
and in in practice it's actually even
less than linear because you just
recompute
the parts of the of the model that you
that you need to when you have new
evidence for a new query
and and again without going into the
gory details why why is this possible
well here's a one side one slide
explanation
the basic assumption that we make here
or there's there's two one is that
the probability of an object given a
class
is the product over its subparts of the
probability of the subpart given the
class so the idea is that
knowing the class of an object breaks it
into independent subparts
which then in turn will have their
classes which will then break them up
further
and so on all the way to individual
relations
and the other one is basically the
mixture model hypothesis is that
the probability of something given a
class is just the sum
over the subclasses of the probability
of that thing that we're interested in
given the subclass times the probability
of the subclass
okay and what these two assumptions buy
us is that now
the structure of the computation is
isomorphic
to the stretch of the knowledge base
everywhere i have
a class being broken into subclasses i
have a sum node
and everywhere i have an object being
broken into into subparts
i have a product node and so there's no
blow up
at all that's why it's slinging it's
like the computation is a copy of the of
the of the knowledge base of the mln so
it takes the same amount of time
or as i mentioned before you know
typically even less
and we've applied this to building a
large
web knowledge base which we extracted
from
dbpd yago and nl all of them very well
known uh
web knowledge graphs or knowledge bases
if you will
it's by largest to our knowledge sorry
by far to our knowledge the largest
first order probabilistic system ever
built
it has millions of objects and billions
of parameters
and yet you can answer any query in this
language
exactly not approximately in sub second
time so you can actually you know
do this interactively you can work with
with a with these models
interactively and of course there have
been many other applications of markov
logic
as well probably the single biggest area
is natural language processing because
of course it's a very natural match
there's a lot of structure
and also a lot of ambiguity um but also
things like social network analysis
robotics computational biology psyc
the famous you know largest knowledge
base ever built uh parts of it
have been turned into mlns using um
you know the ideas that i described here
also personal assistance
uh the the the famous darpa caleb
project that siri came out of used
markov logic as its core inference
engine
and mlns have been widely used and
researched in both
academia and industry not just at the
you know big tech companies but
many others as well so to summarize
i would say that it's fair to say that
at this point we have largely succeeded
in unifying logic and probability
and this is a problem that has
preoccupied you know mathematicians and
philosophers for a long time and
and even been considered unsolvable by
some
there's of course many different
approaches to doing this but the most
general one the most powerful and most
developed one is markov logic which is
why
what i talked about here and it is
essentially just consists of
weighting your first order formulas and
then turning them in that way into a log
linear
model ie into a markov network there's a
bunch of powerful
inference and learning algorithms for it
that we and many others have developed
and i think this can hopefully serve as
a foundation for modern ai
where instead of just having to do a
bunch of hacking to deal with rural
problems you can actually do things in a
more principled way
there's of course much more still to do
um
if you'd like to learn more about markov
logic i recommend
reading this article that came out a
couple of years ago in cacm
there's also a slightly older book which
you see here
it doesn't contain some of the things
that i talked about here but that it's a
pretty good introduction
there's also an open source
implementation called alchemy
and the website where you have not just
alchemy but pointers to
other open source implementations data
sets papers
mlns that you can use modules that you
can combine and so on
and and here's the url thank you
thank you pedro for a fantastic talk so
i'm going to clap for everybody
thank you so much all right
questions please moshe i think probably
yeah go ahead
so you know let's let's look at the rule
all smokers get cancer
i can put some weight on it but what i'd
like to do is not to put a weight on it
but instead to say
this rule is true but in a probabilistic
way which is
all smoker who is for a big independent
probability
let's say i don't know what it is let's
say 0.4 they get cancer
that's what i really would like to say
so the rule will be universally true
but the probability would be on the
implication the implication will be
probabilistic
if i understand you correctly that is
what we're doing here what i'm saying is
that for every
take a very simple mlm right the mln
just says smokes
x for all x with some weight right
this is exactly the same as saying you
know every x smokes
with an independent probability for each
x and this is actually crucial
because if you're familiar with this
history nielsen back in the 80s already
proposed the maximum entropy version of
logic
but the problem is that it took the
whole formula as a unit
so this was not very useful right and
and in particular didn't generalize the
traditional probabilistic models
so so what you said if you have a
formula in the mln that says smokes x
what that does is that every
independently for every person they
smoke with that probability
but where do i put in the where is the
way for me to say
the probability of cancer from smoking
is alpha
that's in the formula that's in the
weight of the second formula so if you
have a formula
uh smokes x implies cancer x the weight
of that formula is the probability of
the implication
now to be very precise it is not the
probability that the consequent holds
given the antecedent
it's a problem that the formula that's
not what i want that's not what i want
because then some people will not smoke
and that's another way to make it true
i want to say for each smoker if this
person smoke
then with probability alpha this person
gets cancer no yes so you can do that so
you can do the following you tell me
what you want that probability to be
and i will you know give you the weight
for the formulas that that corresponds
to
i see any any probability distribution
that you want to put on this
i can give you the pr i can give you the
weights now you can ask the question
which people used to in the early days
right
this was a very natural one which is
then why don't you just specify the
model in terms of probabilities why
why weights right because visual
networks the model specified in terms of
problems
the problem is that then you have an
intractable problem right out front
which is to make sure that all those
probabilities are consistent
i've just given you an enormous amount
of flexibility in allowing
any first order logic statement to be
there and in fact there are people that
used to say that what we did was
impossible right
but now for you and then those problems
that those properties might not be
consistent
right you might be specifying a
probability from one formula
that is compatible with the probability
for another formula if what you do is
specify which for the formulas the
widths can be
anything you want and you always get a
well-defined probability a joint
probability distribution out of it
but whatever the probability
distribution is that you want i can give
you the weights and in fact
this is the maximum entropy inference
problem
maximum entropy inference is precisely
no more no less
than going from the probabilities of the
formulas to the weights
now of course in practice the problems
that we have are consistent when we
learn from data
because they're just the statistics that
we measured on the data right
but if you just wanted to specify
probabilities out of your head then you
would risk
you know making them inconsistent thank
you
thank you pedro uh thank you marcia for
that question anybody else has a
question
yes may i ask something please please
yes hi so i have two questions one is uh
is a simple question about uh the
background
uh and the relation between these you
said that the
the goal is to consol con
somehow combine logic and probability so
how would you
uh say is what would you say is the
relation with the fuzzy logic that
had the same goal if at all and the
second question is
more applied is it really uh does it
really
you talked about application so is there
a really interface with these kind of
um this technology with um
like procedures like that are applied
nowadays in deep learning and so forth
maybe i did not understand how this can
be combined together if at all
yeah thank you so the relation to fuzzy
logic is very simple
and it's it has two parts one is that
fuzzy logic is actually
an alternative to graphical models it's
a propositional language it's not a
relational language
so i can imagine defining a first order
version of a relational version of
fuzzy logic in the same way that what we
define here you can think of as a
relational version of graphical models
okay so this is at a higher level right
in the same way that first our logic is
at a higher level than probabilistic
logic
the second one of course is that these
days people in aya don't do fuzzy logic
because it's unsound
right so you know you could do things
like that but you would have the usual
problems okay
and again it would be proposition loss
for story so deep learning
i didn't go into the details of that but
it's actually fairly straightforward to
take a lot of these deep learning models
and express them in mark of logic so in
fact
when jan lacan first saw me describe um
markov logic in a in a talk at nips he
actually said oh
so what you have here is a language for
defining hamiltonians compactly
which is actually a very apt thing to
say right so
if you think of these you know
neural networks as optimizing an energy
function which is what a lot of them do
and again that's how yan likes likes to
see it then then what mln
allows you to do is to define you know
any energy function that you want
using firsthand logic and by the way i
didn't get into that but you can also
define things you know that are not just
over boolean domains but over numeric
ones
where a lot of these deep learning
models are used okay
but then the benefit that you get is
that
and this is a very big benefit is that
when you define
you know these models in in these deep
models if they're probabilistic if
they're just you know energy based
models then you know you can optimize
them and the two things
at some level are equivalent but if you
actually want to compute probabilities
with them
then you get killed by the partition
function right because the inference is
highly interruptable
in fact jeff hinton famously said that
he's with his whole life under the
shadow of the partition function
and what things like mark of logic and
in particular chartable markov logic
like you do
is actually they carve out a subset
of this world where you actually can
always find answers efficiently
and this subset very importantly is much
larger than the subset of
of low tree with models right the
problem with all these deep networks is
that they high tree with
but the thing here that's very new and
in some ways very surprising is that
you can actually have high tree with
models
where the partition function is still
tractable and those are precisely what
tractable markov logic
zeroes in
a few more questions
so pedro i had a couple of questions one
is
perhaps a quite an obvious one which is
you know
in in the solver domain sat solvers and
model counting solvers will be
constantly making progress and
improve improving their efficiency and
scalability
and i was wondering uh
these newer solvers uh could help
your implementations in in a meaningful
way
because a couple of slides prior to your
last slide you mentioned that you're
already
a very efficient inference at least for
the tractable version
version of so so how can this technology
help you is kind of the broad question
i mean it can certainly help us because
of course the pride that we paid
the price that we paid in track of of
logic is that it's a restricted language
right so there's a lot of things that
would still like to say
right and and our preoccupation from day
one actually has been
to have a setup where if tomorrow you
have a better
say set solver you can just plug it into
here
if tomorrow you have a better ilp you
know induction algorithm you should also
plug that in here or you know take any
of the pieces what we want
we want this to be you know we want the
people who use this to be able to use it
without knowing what's under the
hood but we also want the people who
work on the pieces under the hood
to be able to plug in the new part
without knowing the rest
and in particular the problems that
you're improving that i described here
is based on dpl
but you know there's versions of this
that exist now in fact
some of the early ones that we have
we're based on other sad solvers
and again the idea is that if tomorrow
you have a better version of dpl or a
completely different set solver
you should be able to plug it in here
and and in some sense
get the probability added for free so if
you come at this from different point of
view
from the logical inference the way to
think about this in fact
we had a paper in a in a book about you
know uncertainty in the semantic web
that the title was just add weights you
have your logical formalism
you have your logical inference engine
you add weights to it and now instead
you're doing you know probability
computations so that's the idea of
course
depending on the exact set solver this
could be simpler or have some you know
you know subtleties but this has been
done a number of times now
and again the goal in the future is that
you know every time that set solvers get
better by an order of magnitude
inference in markov logic should also
get better by another magnet
sounds great i had one more question
which had to do with
nlp systems i don't know enough about
nlp unfortunately but
uh you're aware of gp2 and gp
gpt2 and gpt3 right so i'm assuming
they're built on a different
architecture than uh markov logic
networks is it would that be fair
no they are so they're built on on
something called the transformer
and and you know which is built on
something called attention
and and and you know and they use what
is called contextual embedding
and these are all very interesting and
powerful ideas um
the question i have there is that you
know they are susceptible to some very
simple logical
inference issues these birds based
systems
and would it be right to say that markov
logic network-based systems
are not likely to be uh susceptible to
those kind of logical issues
i mean exactly right so but there's two
sides to this one is that
i mean these models honestly are subject
to all sorts of crap
like that mark of logicism right nobody
really knows what's going on there
right it works some of the times on the
time it does ridiculous things and
nobody really understands what's going
on
right so it's good that it works right
on the other hand it's not a very
satisfying set of things
markov logic as i described here doesn't
have any of those problems by design
but it's not scalable to the same degree
right and of course
i showed you here one interesting subset
called tractor lamar called logic
we're actually currently working on a
different one so
you want me to think about this like
practical markup there's like two major
kinds to oversimplify
of tractable languages there's the logic
programming type ones
and then there's a description logic
type ones tractable markov logic is a
description logic version of markov
logic
we're currently working on a logic
programming one which we call
you know tensor logic which you can
actually
precisely specify all these models and
the attention mechanisms and
the modules that transformers you know
all the way up to gpt3 are based on
in this language and then get the
corresponding benefits so this hasn't
been published yet but it's something
that i'm
very excited about awesome all right
thank you again for a great
it tacos it was a pleasure thank you
thank you a lot
our next speaker is vivek srikhmar vivek
can you please share your slides
uh yes pedro on shares
and uh it's